all right let's bring in republican
arkansas senator
tom cotton senator good morning to you
good morning everyone what do you make
of the fact peter just mentioned this
that the federal government is taking
the extraordinary measure of
sending out word to any federal employee
hey how would you like to leave that
boring job in washington
and come down to our southern border for
up to 120 days because it's all messed
up down here
well i was there last week and what i
saw was an absolute crisis
uh these scenes are heartbreaking of
course you have young moms and dads with
small children sitting under a bridge in
the middle of the night waiting to be
processed
inside some of these facilities you have
small children without even parents
there who are sleeping
um right next to each other in in large
i guess you might call them cages guys
uh they've replaced the champlain scents
with plaque with plastic
size plastic walls but still they're
packed in tight but all of that
all that steve is addressing the
symptoms not the cause asking federal
employees to deploy the border
addressing the symptoms not the cause
the cause is joe biden opening our
border
and saying anyone who comes here can get
in especially anyone who has a child
under the age of 18. well guess what you
get tens
of thousands and soon hundreds of
thousands or more of people showing up
with young kids
i spoke to several of them on friday
night or thursday night
underneath that bridge and i asked them
why they came almost to a person
they said to find a job or to get a
better life they didn't say they were
facing persecution because of their race
or ethnicity or sex or political views
or religion
they came because they want a better
life which i can understand but
that's not basis for asylum under our
country's laws
they are coming because joe biden
dismantled the highly effective policy
to the trump administration they could
reinstitute all those today
they could say we're going to turn back
everyone who comes to the border because
of the pandemic they could say you have
to
adjudicate your asylum claims in the
first country you enter after you leave
your country most likely guatemala
and if you get to our border you have to
remain in mexico all of those were
highly effective policies and not a
single one
not a single one resulted in kids or
even adults
being turned back into the mexican
desert as joe biden and others in
his administration have lied they put
them back on planes they sent them home
and after you send them home on one
plane
and their neighbors and their countrymen
see that guess what
the rest of them stopped coming yeah
right senator ted cruz was on that trip
with you
and he was at a facility in donna i
think it was donna texas
and a staffer came up to him and said
you need to put down your phone you're
not allowed to record
this watch this you don't want the
pictures taken
the rules are arbitrary and they're
designed to keep the american people
in dignity and respect that's all we ask
well
you're asking is this dignity and
respect look at these
you're right and this is a dangerous
place please don't treat that and your
policies
unfortunately are trying to hide them i
understand you were instructed
when 18 senators came down the people
give them
i respect them and i want to fix this
situation we all want to the
administration you're working
for is responsible for these conditions
senator tell us what you experienced
what's going on in that video
yeah i saw the same thing this little
political apparatchik
who's been working for the bible
administration for two weeks came down
and
tried to tell senators in my group like
dan sullivan to put their phones away or
they were going to be escorted down to
the facility and it made me wonder who
was going to actually do that
says that border patrol agrees that joe
biden's policy
is utter and total failure that's the
thing we consistently heard
is if you let them in more will come not
shockingly if you say
that minors get into the country or that
anyone who shows up at the
child under the age of six gets into the
country guess what you get more of them
in the country
it leads to the heartbreaking scenes
that we've seen in some of these
pictures and videos
from my colleagues but again those are
all just the symptoms not the cause the
cause
is letting them into the country in the
first place and once they're in
they will never go home right many of
them aren't even getting a notice to
appear in court
and if they do appear in court and they
get a notice of removal of deportation
well joe biden has halted deportations
yeah these people know that they can get
into our country and they're never gonna
have to go home and they can lead a
better life
that is the ultimate failure of our
immigration system it could all be
solved by simply saying
you cannot get in do not come if you do
we will send you home
you don't have a big heart when you say
every unaccompanied minor gets to stay
you have a you have a i think you have
you're not thinking this through
because if every kid comes what about
the kids that are here we don't exactly
have a social
infrastructure right now overrun with
cash uh we're 27 trillion dollars in
debt
we have a lot of foster kids that need
homes we have a lot of kids that need to
be
to be adopted why are we taking in four
different countries
and i'll bring something else up they
made two ridiculous statements
joe biden says he replaced a light on
the city block and he stopped gangs
in uh in in south in central america
remember that from thursday
and then yesterday kate benningfeld says
we're going to put money in to open up
boys clubs in these triangle uh in these
triangle countries
that's right they're here because there
are no boys clubs
that's really going to make tremendous
progress maybe we can play intramural
basketball or
tag that will really stem this so i mean
some of the things they're saying are
farcical they're never pressed on them
yeah they are brian and let's look at
the facts as well
i mean these countries like guatemala
and el salvador
and honduras look they're not
heaven on earth but there are plenty of
places in those countries that are safe
and you have a first duty if you want to
seek asylum is to seek it within your
own country move to a safer part of your
own country
and those countries as a whole have
lower murder rates than some american
cities like baltimore
so these people who are claiming they
want to come here because in zika
sagalam have no basis under our law to
seek asylum
just because your country has some
violence just because it's poorer than
the united states
doesn't give you a basis to come here
you have to be the victim of systematic
persecution for things like your
religious views or your political views
or your race or your sex
not a single one with whom i spoke
claimed that the other night they all
were responding
to joe biden and to his decisions to
allow the men
and if we let them in more will come by
the hundreds of thousands they're coming
it's going to cost
hard working taxpayers billions of
dollars and it's going to put not just
our border security
at risk it's going to put our national
security at risk as well